[Musique]
la retraite à 64 ans c'est
définitivement non ce mercredi matin une
cinquantaine de personnes réunies à
Rambouillet à l'appel de l'intersyndical
elles se sont mobilisées devant la
permanence de la députée de la dixième
circonscription des Yvelines Aurore
berger qui n'était pas présente sur
place l'objectif pour les syndicats
interpeller la chef de fil des députés
renaissances pour le retrait de la
réforme des retraites le texte de loi
est examiné jusqu'à vendredi à
l'ensemble des nationales et
l'intersydicale des Yvelines a demandé
une audience à Aurore berger à Walt de
début de l'examen de du projet de loi
pour lui expliquer nos arguments sur
pourquoi on est contre ce projet de loi
elle n'a jamais répondu à nos demandes
donc du coup on vient pour lui dire
qu'on est là qu'on aimerait bien qu'elle
ne vote pas ce projet de loi ce jeudi
5ème jour de grève nationale contre la
réforme une manifestation est prévue
dans les rues de Versailles
les Yvelines ont officialisé aujourd'hui
leur participation au capital de Thoiry
bioénergie depuis 2018 l'usine produit
du biométhane à partir de déchets
organiques au profit du zoo et de 8
communes yinoises le montant de
l'opération pour le département s'élève
à 2 millions d'euros soit 31% du capital
le cirque Europa et adcf association de
défense des cirques de familles ont
déposé plein de contre alira Bay le
maire de Trappes fin 2020 la
municipalité avait publié un arrêté pour
interdire les cirques avec des animaux
sauvages la DCF prévoit de fortes
mobilisations pour protester contre la
décision du maire
la région Île-de-France lance un appel à
projet pour donner un nouveau souffle
aux îles de loisirs francilienne et les
rendre plus attractives dans le
département des Yvelines ce sont les
trois îles de loisirs aval de Seine
boucle de scène et Saint-Quentin en
Yvelines qui sont concernés le dépôt de
candidature se termine le 31 mars à 17
heures
l'association handicien dispose
désormais d'une délégation locale à
Villepreux cette nouvelle antenne portée
par Anne-Sophie Sablon Maury permet de
former davantage de chiens pour le
moment ils sont trop à bénéficier d'une
formation chaque semaine à l'école Jean
Rostand
[Musique]